the ego is not master in its own house
[Music]
neurosis is the inability to tolerate
ambiguity where it is there shall ego be
from error to error one discovers the
entire truth
he who knows how to wait need make no
concessions
[Music]
if children could if adults knew
there are no mistakes
neurosis is no excuse for bad manners
being entirely honest with oneself is a
good exercise
anatomy is destiny
[Music]
how bold and one gets when one is sure
of being loved
[Music]
the madman is a dreamer awake
public self is a conditioned construct
of the inner psychological self
a woman should soften but not weaken the
man
my love is something valuable to me
which i ought not to throw away without
reflection
[Music]
one day in retrospect the years of
struggle will strike you as the most
beautiful
[Music]
out of your vulnerabilities will come
your
strength when one does not have what one
wants one must want what one has
the more perfect a person is on the
outside the more demons they have on the
inside
[Music]
love in the form of longing and
deprivation lowers the self-regard
men are more moral than they think and
far more immoral than they can imagine
immorality no less than morality has at
all times found support in religion
[Music]
everyone owes nature a death
[Music]
man has as it were become a kind of
prosthetic god
america is a mistake a giant mistake
the intention that man should be happy
is not in the plan of creation
[Music]
i never want to belong to any club that
would have someone like me as a member
[Music]
smoking is indispensable if one has
nothing to kiss
[Music]
where such men love they have no desire
and where they desire they cannot love
dreams are the royal road to the
unconscious
in mourning it is the world which has
become poor and empty in melancholy and
is the ego itself
[Music]
the mind is like an iceberg it floats
with one seventh of its bulk above water
[Music]
whoever loves becomes humble those who
love have so to speak pawned a part of
their narcissism
where does the thought go when it's
forgotten
[Music]
we are never so defenseless against
suffering as when we love
[Music]
in matters of sexuality we are at
present every one of us ill or well
nothing but hypocrites
[Music]
it is impossible to overlook the extent
to which civilization is built up upon a
renunciation of instinct
[Music]
the liberty of the individual is no gift
of civilization it was greatest before
there was any civilization
religion is an illusion and it derives
its strength from the fact that it falls
in with our instinctual desires
in the depths of my heart i can't help
being convinced that my dear fellow men
with a few exceptions are worthless
[Music]
you wanted to kill your father in order
to be your father yourself
now you are your father but a dead
father
beauty has no obvious use nor is there
any clear cultural necessity for it yet
civilization could not do without it
[Music]
the virtuous man contents himself with
dreaming that which the wicked man does
in actual life
[Music]
conservatism is too often a welcome
excuse for lazy minds loath to adapt
themselves to fast-changing conditions
[Music]
no neurotic harbors thoughts of suicide
which are not murderous impulses against
others redirected upon himself
[Music]
the unconscious of one human being can
react upon that of another without
passing through the conscious
men are strong so long as they represent
a strong idea they become powerless when
they oppose it
the more the fruits of knowledge become
accessible to men the more widespread is
the decline of religious belief
a religion even if it calls itself a
religion of love must be hard and
unloving to those who do not belong to
it
civilized society is perpetually menaced
with disintegration through this primary
hostility of men towards one another
[Music]
what progress we are making in the
middle ages they would have burned me
now they are content with burning my
books
it is a predisposition of human nature
to consider an unpleasant idea untrue
and then it is easy to find arguments
against it
no our science is no illusion but an
illusion it would be to suppose that
what science cannot give us we can get
elsewhere
[Music]
the behavior of a human being in sexual
matters is often a prototype for the
whole of his other modes of reaction in
life
most people do not really want freedom
because freedom involves responsibility
and most people are frightened of
responsibility
[Music]
words and magic were in the beginning
one and the same thing and even today
words retain much of their magical power
the creative writer does the same as the
child at play he creates a world of
fantasy which he takes very seriously
[Music]
the dream is the liberation of the
spirit from the pressure of external
nature a detachment of the soul from the
fetters of matter
our memory has no guarantees at all and
yet we bow more often than is
objectively justified to the compulsion
to believe what it says
[Music]
where the questions of religion are
concerned people are guilty of every
possible kind of insincerity and
intellectual misdemeanor
[Music]
never believe your wife if she says she
has forgiven resentment
great decisions in the realm of thought
and momentous discoveries and solutions
of problems are only possible to an
individual working in solitude
[Music]
neurotics complain of their illness but
they make the most of it and when it
comes to taking it away from them they
will defend it like a lion is her young
a man should not strive to eliminate his
complexes but to get into accord with
them they are legitimately what directs
his conduct in the world
[Music]
you